good morning y'all welcome to my morning
coffee thoughts
today i have chai tea
so i guess it's not coffee but
today
i want to talk about
um i don't know just how social media
changes content creators brains and i
think it the general population too
but it's something i noticed like
before i was a content creator when i
was like watching all these content
creators
um
i remember thinking like
how many people do they really argue
with in real life
um
if you guys hear noises it's my dog
she's like eating anyways um
because oftentimes you'll heal content
creators like talking about like how all
the girls are the worst and
how
you know leftists liberals like they
always come after them but i'm like in
real day-to-day life like you don't
really argue with people that much like
nobody's really going to come up and say
anything to you
and it's funny because we're about
instances where girls talking all this
[ __ ] about me
on my team
y'all know who you i don't think they
watch these chats we all know who you
are and it's funny because the second i
see them they're perfectly nice and
normal
and some people would say that maybe
like they're fake
probably granted
granted
but the point is like most people don't
really have the time or the energy to
argue with you in real life like people
are busy they got [ __ ] to do
and most people aren't even thinking
about you
so
when i would hear content creators
say oh the left calls me this this this
and this and i'm like well how often in
real life does that really happen
and i argue with people in real life all
the time but and 90 of the time people
are cordial they respect you they don't
they don't really like do much and so i
remember like looking at these content
creators and thinking they were kind of
crazy because because
they just felt like everyone was out to
get them but i'm like are they really
are they really
we take so much heat i'm like come on in
real life how often does that happen
i'm not saying there's certain content
creators i'm sure
but 90 of the time when you talk to
people if you're nice to them and you're
excited to see them they're nice to you
i might talk [ __ ] about you later but
like i i don't even blame people for
talking [ __ ]
sometimes i talk [ __ ] like
people say [ __ ] like
it's not the end of the world and that's
the other thing like women i think we
take so personally when we find out
someone's like talking about us or like
behind our back
but i've thought about this a lot i
don't think i'm entitled to know every
single thing that someone says about me
behind my back
i don't
there's line where it's like
disrespectful but
i just think at times like we love our
family more than anyone in the world but
we all complain about our family
sometimes
don't get me wrong we'll do it to their
face
but i don't know i've always noticed
that the girls that are like obsessed
with what everyone's saying behind their
back
they're the ones that are talking about
[ __ ] and the girls that don't really
care like
like because me i'm like hey i'd rather
just not know for the most part
um
the girls like that like we don't talk
as much [ __ ]
but i really do think
that content creators our brains change
in some way and we're like more agitated
because in order to like succeed in a
lot of like red pill spaces and a lot of
youtube spaces you need to like put
conflict at the forefront and you're
always debating and so i think something
like that changes a part of your brain
because
i'll catch myself doing it i'll be like
these hoes are tiring and some of them
are oh my god you guys have seen me on
camera but i can't discount the fact
that and the majority of the time people
are nice
the majority of the time everyone's
respectful
flaky though
that i do have a right to complain about
these homes do be flaky
i don't know but
and also a lot of times i think people
take [ __ ] so personally on the internet
like you guys remember when the abba and
preach and fresh and fit drama was going
on
like that that was such a big
like fashion fight got into their
panties in a freaking bunch because
album preached like criticized them
and then they went like ballistic i'm
like
i'm i'm the female
like what don't why do i think that's
not a big deal
and i just feel like as content creators
you should know and this isn't just a
shot at fresh and fit or whatever like
i've seen this with multiple content
creators you should know people are
gonna make hit pieces on you and i i for
real i don't really take that [ __ ]
personal i'm like
like and then i talked to my dad about
this he says well what did you expect
you're a content creator of course of
course people are going to talk [ __ ] of
course people are going to make hit
pieces on you and what i've noticed is
that
the more you just ignore people
and you're successful on your own they
always come back
and that's the crazy thing like the
bigger you get and the more you just
focus on yourself and you become
successful and it doesn't even
necessarily need to be career wise it
could be family wise it could be
um
body wise like losing weight like
the people that talk the most [ __ ]
love you in a way and this is it's kind
of weird but
i think that hate
is closer to love
like the girls that i know that talk the
most [ __ ] about me and i like hear about
it they're always the ones to like talk
to me first when i walk into a room
they're always the first to like
interact with me and it's just like
um
i don't really
take that [ __ ] as personal as some
people do
but
i think as content creators
i just feel like we should all know
this is the industry you're in like
you can't pick you can't pick this
industry and feel and get mad when
people make hit pieces on you i swear to
god
i will never i will never take that [ __ ]
personal because this is this is the
industry that we picked
now is there a line
sure
sure there i think your personal friends
your personal family that that is the
line
but if you if you pick content creation
people make hit pieces on you i don't
really feel bad for you
and when it happens to me which it does
i don't really feel bad for me either
my mom says i need to work on my empathy
skills
um
another thing that i was thinking about
is
long-term thinking and this is something
i didn't think about
every time like girls i think as girls
we often want the security of a
relationship online
and
like because to us commitment is
currency right that's what we want guys
want sex we want commitment so
we want
to post the relationship to show we have
a boyfriend all that stuff and i
understand that and and that used to be
me all the time but i was thinking about
this like long term i'm like i'm gonna
get married one day i don't really want
pictures of me and all my ex
boyfriends on the internet
and i was thinking because me and my
last boyfriend did a ton of content
together and you know didn't work out i
was broken up and i i scrubbed pretty
much everything off of my page that i
could find anyway
i mean we made so many videos who knows
there could be one or two i left but
like i think i got them all
and it's like i'm gonna get married
someday and they're somewhere out there
there are videos of us we're not doing
anything crazy like don't don't don't
get wild in these comments sometimes you
guys get wild
um like we're not
it should they're like
light-hearted videos but
still like i don't know i don't want
evidence of that
like just like i don't want my future
husband's evidence of him and his
ex-girlfriend all over the internet so i
was thinking i'm like i think
none of y'all are gonna know who i'm
dating until i have a ring i swear to
god
respectfully i love you guys i love you
guys i just
anyways sorry these are very random
thoughts today that i've been having
um if you're still here appreciate it i
know i
i babble sometimes
but i love you guys um
thank you so much and i will talk to you
next time don't forget to subscribe